It's time for another check-in with the Drew van.
Our road tripping couple Noah and Karen have been
making their way across the country from California
and there'll be joining us here in New York in a full,
a few days.
But today they're helping us surprise a very
special small business owner in Washington, DC.
There they are now.
But first let's meet Kathy Oliphant-Wilson.
She's a veteran who thought outside the box
and turned her passion for giving presents
into a business with her company Blush Boxes
that delivers curated gift boxes.
And Kathy is joining us now along with ABC seven reporter
and our good friend of the show Kidd O'Shay.
Hi Kidd, hi Kathy.
Hi Drew, oh my god I can't believe I'm meeting you.
What a wonderful opportunity.
Thank you so much
I feel the exact same way
and Kidd I'm always happy to see you.
Great to see you again Drew,
thank you for having me back.
Beautiful, Kathy, please tell me
about your extraordinary small business
and how it came about.
So Drew, I decided to start my business
about a year and a half ago, right before the onset
of COVID because I wanted to utilize my gifts,
my passions, and my abilities to give myself back into,
back to the planet.
I really wanted to make sure that I was operating
in my gift and transitioning from my career to my calling.
I felt like it was important for me to again give my gifts
and my talents to people and to help them deal with
the stresses that we're currently experiencing right now.
Absolutely incredible.
I love that.
We would be honored if you would join
our little book of small businesses gift guide.
(cheering)
If you go to the DrewBarrymoreShow.com
you'll be seeing Kathy's amazing blush boxes featured
and then it will live permanently on our website
for everyone to see and go to.
Thank you so much.
How cool is that?
So cool.
By the way Kathy have you heard about our Drew van?
I sure have.
Noah and Karen just pulled up
with something special for you.
They are here.
Alright.
Look at that.
Oh my god!
(laughing)
It's $5,000.
And it's a donation to Blush Boxes.
Oh my gosh.
The curated gifted virtual hug, Kathy.
We want to help continue to make your business
the success it deserves to be and is.
Thank you so, so very much.
Oh my goodness, thank you.
$5,000 check right behind you, all yours.
I can go back there?
You can go back there.
Go touch it.
Thank you Kidd.
And Kathy so much.
Thank you so much Noah and Karen,
we'll see you in New York soon and to all of you at home
I hope you have a great rest of your day.
Take all of this goodness with you.
It's for you.
And thank you for joining us so much.
We'll see you soon.
(upbeat music)